demi lovato
the fiercest and fittest she's ever been
and dishing to Edie about balancing it
all you've seen the happiest that you've
ever been both physically and mentally
what do you think that you've learned
about yourself the most in the last year
well I take care of my mental health
it's definitely something that I
prioritize as well as my physical health
I see a therapist two days a week I
reach out to people but whatever I'm
struggling with something I work out I
eat clean I have a healthy support
system around me I do everything that it
takes to maintain a happy healthy
lifestyle you've been so open and candid
about your struggles and about body
shame or that's something that you're
still dealing with I don't really deal
with body shamers anymore because they
don't look at it and I think the more
attention that you give it the more
power it has over you I focus on just
what I see in the mirror and that's a
beautiful person and regardless of what
I think of my body that day I know that
nobody can take Who I am away from and
if I see a comment that says that she's
fat or whatever it I let it roll off my
back
because I just know that I'm healthy and
I'm doing everything that I can to be
healthy whatever my body is right now is
what it is so love it or hate it I'm
still gonna go like you're so busy so
what's the secret with balancing fitness
because I see that you work out all the
time and your career you have to
prioritize what's important to you and
to me fitness is very important to me it
helps with my physical strength but more
importantly my mental strength I like to
Train MMA so I'll do kickboxing boxing
Muay Thai and Jiu Jitsu and I think my
favorite probably has to be jiu-jitsu is
it true that you are or almost are a
blue belt yes almost the Wu belts I've
been a white belt for over a year now
and so it's time it goes white blue
purple brown black so I'll have a blue
belt probably by the end of the year a
fitness queen it
make sense dummy has teamed up with
fabletics owner Kate Hudson to create
her own line of athletic wear for the
brand we actually did meet in a gym
which was really funny and ironic she
was doing like this arm workout and so
then I was like can I join and she was
like yeah and she was super cool super
sweet they came to me with the idea and
I could not say no I love fat blood X
and I love Kate and you had full say or
how much they do you have yeah I have
total say do you draw do you sketch are
you in the room giving ideas I'm not
very good at drawing or sketching so I
let other people do that but I
definitely give my input my ideas and I
pick the colors and this collection
coming out is going to be really cooled